un bon soir le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes le lundi 23 novembre voici les
titres de ce journal leterme a le vent
en poupe notamment depuis les dernières
élections municipales le budget
participatif autrement dit est donnée
aux citoyens la possibilité d'attribuer
une partie du budget de leur
collectivité à un projet de leur choix
de nombreuses communes l'ont adopté mais
aussi la région ile de france qui a
lancé la deuxième session de son budget
participatif écologique et solidaire
c'est un classique de la fin d'année la
vente des calendriers en porte à porte
des postiers éboueurs ou encore pompiers
avec la crise sanitaire les soldats du
feu des yvelines ont décidé de ne pas en
vendre en présentiel
il sera tout de même possible d'en
acheter en ligne et puis l approche de
la journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes mercredi rencontre avec
louise dubray elle est psychologue au
sein de l'institut woman safe à
saint-germain-en-laye portrait à la fin
de cette édition
mais avant de débuter une lettre ouverte
qui a été transmise pour rappel le 14
novembre dernier
ces mères qui ont écrit cette lettre
lancé un appel au président de la
république pour l'égalité républicaine
pour les quartiers prioritaires plus de
100 mer mais aussi à des présidents
d'agglomérations et associations a
demandé au chef de l'état d'attribuer au
moins 1% de plan de relance de l'état
c'est-à-dire un milliard d'euros aux
quartiers prioritaires parmi les
signataires une dizaine est d'élu des
yvelines vous les voyez à l'image ce
lundi neuf maires dont catherine arnould
pour chanteloup les vignes ont ici ont
été ainsi reçu par jean castex et
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ou
visio ils ont fait le point lors d'une
conférence de presse à la mi-journée
d'après les édiles le premier ministre
les a entendus sur la question du plan
de relance et devrait bien en attribuer
1 % des montants à ces quartiers et les
élus attendent désormais les retombées
sur le terrain notamment pour l'impact
vis-à-vis des associations fragilisé
avec la crise sanitaire avec de nombreux
non renouvellement d'inscription écouter
catherine arnaud interrogé par nicolas
landry les réponses qui nous ont été
données sont un peu un peu déconcertante
puisque paraît-il le retour des
associations n'est pas du tout le retour
des mers et que les associations voient
arriver
l'argent qui a été déclinée soit 50 75
millions pas ça dépend un peu des jours
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai
questionné mes petites associations
sportives et bien elles n'ont pas vu la
couleur de l'argent de l'état et celles
qui ont voulu sont tellement difficulté
c'est pas des pros ils font ils ont pas
tous fait sciences po il passe pas tous
leurs temps derrière un écran
ce sont des gens qui travaillent avec
des habitants et de travail pour les
jeunes le temps que les dispositifs par
exemple sorte moi j'ai l'exemple et le
20 septembre la ministre nous en parle
les associations essayent désespérément
et puis le 15 octobre on leur dit que
l'exercice est clos et elles sont
nombreuses vous pouvez questionner mais
les autres collègues maires manque c'est
donc qu'il ya à la fois de la
désespérance dans les associations
sportives qui sont essentiellement des
bénévoles du désintérêt liés à des
problèmes financiers pour les familles
et donc vous savez bien ce que ça est ce
que ça représente c'est à la fois du
lien social
et puis de la capacité aux enfants de
s'ouvrir à autre chose que l'or va juste
scolarisation en milieu familial ce dont
nous avons besoin sur notre territoire
qui est en jeu un conseil national des
solutions va d'ailleurs être lancée pour
suivre la mise en oeuvre des
propositions du gouvernement sur le
terrain samedi près de 200 personnes se
sont rassemblées devant la préfecture
des yvelines à versailles
leur revendication demandé le maintien
de l'instruction à domicile emmanuel
macron entend là limitée est
drastiquement dans le cadre du plan de
lutte contre les séparatismes pour les
manifestants présents il s'agit d'un
droit essentiel sur place
célia tsongo le récit d'astrid bergère
cinquante mille enfants ont été
scolarisés à la maison en france cette
année
cela pourrait ne plus être possible sauf
exception cela fait partie du projet de
loi pour lutter contre les séparatismes
annoncé par emmanuel macron c'est pour
pouvoir continuer l'instruction à
domicile que près de 200 personnes ont
manifesté à versailles le système en
place fonctionne déjà très bien c'est à
dire que
on est contrôlée par la mairie par
l'éducation nationale
il ya déjà tout un arsenal législatif
complètement fonctionnel alors après
s'il ya un manque de moyens il faudrait
peut-être pallier à ce manque de moyens
mais comme il ya aucun lien qui est fait
entre
le séparatisme ou une quelconque forme
d'extrémisme et l'instruction en famille
je ne comprends pas cette fois en fait
les parents présents veulent aussi
montrer qu'ils sont chaque situation
familiale est différente et chacun a ses
propres raisons de faire l'école à la
maison sont nés là aussi c'est avec
certaines revendications et pour
rappeler certains principes de base pour
nous la liberté c'est un fait c'est un
droit qui constitue notre parti et pour
nous c'est insoutenable de penser que la
liberté finalement elle n'est plus au
principe général est que l'exception va
devenir la règle
pourquoi ce principe il est il est
essentiel il a été très bien pensé c'est
que la loi ne pourra jamais pensé à
toute cette diversité de situations le
projet de loi globale sur la lutte
contre le séparatisme devrait être
présenté en conseil des ministres début
décembre à l'actualité c'est aussi
toujours l'épidémie de kovy 19 emmanuel
macron doit s'exprimer demain mardi pour
faire quelques annonces notamment des
allègements sont attendus sur le
confinement en cours il ne sera pas
encore question de déconfinement avec
des données qui sont certes en
amélioration mais qui restent mauvaises
dans les yvelines le taux de positivité
le taux d'incidence est à dire le nombre
de personnes infectées pour 100000
habitants continuent de baisser
ça c'est nouveau pour la première fois
depuis plusieurs semaines le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
également diminué en ile de france
s'établissant hier à 83% en une semaine
33 personnes supplémentaires ont été
hospitalisés du coronavirus dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois mais moins deux
patients sont en réanimation depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et 842 sont
mortes du 142 personnes sont mortes dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois
[Musique]
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
le terme de budget participatif a de
plus en plus de succès autrement dit
donner aux citoyens la possibilité
d'attribuer une partie du budget de leur
commune à un projet de leur choix
s'était notamment au programme des
dernières élections municipales beaucoup
de candidats avaient ce thème comme
thème de campagne pour en parler astrid
bergère est avec moi sur ce plateau
bonsoir dansant grégory de la rédaction
de tv 60,18 les communes y vino s'y
mettent également à ce budget
participatif
oui depuis quelques mois de nombreuses
communes en france lance des budgets
participatifs et les yvelines n'y
échappe pas c'est une façon d'intégrer
les habitants au choix des municipalités
alors à buc c'était une promesse de la
nouvelle équipe ils ont alloué 100 mille
euros pour ce projet ça représente
environ 1% du budget d'investissement de
la ville
alors à partir de 16 ans chaque du quoi
peut proposer un sujet sur les thèmes
suivants cadre de vie mobilité culture
jeunesse sports et éducation solidarité
et santé prévention et sécurité
jusqu'au 27 novembre ils peuvent soit
envoyé aux jets directement gérée à
l'adresse mail cabinet du maire @ neri
tiré du point fr ou à partie lundi de
déposer directement que la plate forme
de participation citoyenne
ensuite le calendrier sera la toute
première semaine de décembre il y aura
un comité de présélection qui est
composé de deux élus à la majorité de
deux zébus de la minorité de trois
citoyens tirés au sort et des agents des
services municipaux qui vont pré
sélectionner les projets en fonction des
thèmes à l'ordre du 7 décembre 29
janvier les agents de la ville vont
faire l'étude de la faisabilité des
projets en fonction de cette étude des
projets réalisables dans l'année 2000 21
seront retenues et ils seront ensuite
proposées au vote des habitants
alors cette phase de vote aura lieu du
1er au 12 février
les projets retenus seront annoncées au
conseil municipal de mars 2021 à
villepreux le projet dévégétalisation
des écoles a été retenu parmi d'autres
projets franciliens
pour le budget participatif écologique
et solidaire mis en place par la région
la ville va obtenir dix mille euros sur
les vingt-sept mille euros nécessaires
pour la faisabilité du projet là pour
l'instant on va être dans une phase
d'étude
on va être dans une phase de
concertation comme je le disais
l'objectif c'est que les travaux
puissent peut-être commencer en fin
d'année prochaine mais que ans puisque
même avancé très rapidement on a quatre
écoles qui sont ciblés par ce dispositif
est donc voilà une vraie satisfaction de
voir qu'il ya eu aussi une une certaine
appétence des villes provient pour ce
sujet et via un mécanisme de
participation citoyenne à ces nouveaux
qui a plutôt bien marché donc encore une
fois sortir 15e sur 460 projets pour une
commune d'un tout petit peu plus de dix
mille habitants c'est vraiment une belle
satisfaction
alors la commune pense déjà au prochain
projet qui pourrait être soumis au
budget participatif de la région comme
le compost le vélo mais aussi des
projets qui seront proposés par les
agriculteurs de la ville merci astrid
pour toutes ces précisions
il n'y a pas que les communes qui se
sont mises au budget participatif la
région ile-de-france au siam il aussi en
place avec une deuxième session qui a
débuté en octobre et qui va se
poursuivre jusqu'en décembre pour le
dépôt des dossiers mais ça va aussi se
poursuivre jusqu'en mars 2021 pour en
parler avec moi jean philippe dugoin
clément bonsoir bonsoir vice président
de la région ile de france en charge de
l'environnement du développement durable
et de l'aménagement je précise que vous
êtes également le maire de la commune de
mennecy qui est dans un département
limitrophe des yvelines c'est bien sûr
le département de l'essonne
déjà sur cette thématique du budget
participatif on voit de nombreuses
communes franchissent le pas des
collectivités aussi à l'image de la
région ile-de-france ouvrir partager la
décision finalement avec le citoyen est
ce qu'on ne peut pas faire sans
aujourd'hui ce que ça ça a du sens
aujourd'hui sur une région sensible et
compliqué que sur une commune parce
qu'on est à l'échelle de luz million
trois cent mille habitants la belgique
ses 11 millions d'habitants dont on est
l'échelle d'un pays
ça nous a obligés à dématérialiser
intégralement nos process mais la usta
énormément tant sur l'environnement que
la thématique on a retenu c'est que
permettre aux citoyens de devenir acteur
et de ne pas être uniquement des
consommateurs ou des observateurs c'est
l'implication individuelle les gens dans
la transition environnementale
on souhaite porter et de ce point de vue
là les budgets participatifs sa
énormément de france et puis pour nous à
l'échelle de la région
c'est aussi un élément du plan de
relance régional on mobilise 100
millions d'euros annuellement pour ce
budget participatif environnementale et
sociale en signant et l'objectif est que
ce soit de l'argent qu'ils aillent très
vite irriguées dans les territoires pour
contribué à amoindrir le choc économique
auquel on va être confronté
particulièrement en ile de france et
pour ce faire du coup la région met sur
la table 500 millions d'euros sur cinq
ans vous l'avez dit un budget
participatif qui est écologique et
solidaire avec une deuxième session qui
est ouvert depuis octobre la première
elle s'est achevée au début de l'automne
les franciliens ont pu voter en ligne
pour 472 projet coup de coeur le bilan
de cette première session qu'elle est il
est ce que il est bon le premier bilan
que vous faites il est excellent on a
été initialement on avait prévu deux
heures deux appels à projets en lançant
cela juste après les municipales pour
pâques et d'exploitation politique la
crise de la coville le report des
élections nous ont permis d'avoir un
seul appel à projets est pour quelque
chose qui est nouveau sur lequel il n'y
a pas de retours d'expériences où on est
sur un démarrage de communication et
très honnêtement à les impliquer des
gens sur ce qu'ils ne touchent pas la
crise du poro nabi rue c'est compliqué
avoir presque 700 dossiers qu'ils soient
déposées avoir plus de 470 dossier qui
puisse être retenu votée par les
franciliens
et bien c'est une très grosse
satisfaction c'est un peu plus de 80
millions d'euros qui auront été injectés
en allant de micro projets qu'on pu être
aidés à hauteur de 1000 1500 euros
jusqu'à des projets extrêmement lourds
ont pu bénéficier de quelques centaines
de milliers d'euros de dette
supplémentaire par rapport à ce que nous
aurions à porter c'est une véritable
satisfaction alors vous l'avez dit on
vient de lancer le 2
appel à projets pour tenir compte de la
crise et du deuxième confinement on a
repoussé jusqu'au 4 décembre les dépôts
de dossiers et donc tous les temps si
bien les collectivités les associations
des entreprises qui sont intéressés
peuvent encore pour une dizaine de jours
déposer leur dossier
c'est extrêmement simple on a allégé au
maximum les procédures
il suffit d'aller sur budget
participatif at-il de france.fr le
déposer déposer ces deux nuits fournir
un explicatif de ce qu'on souhaite
porter et les dossiers qui
correspondront au règlement
d'intervention seront soumis au vote des
franciliens
je pense début février alors si on
revient sur la première session je crois
si juste sous les 10 472 projet qui ont
qu à bénéficier de ce budget
participatif qui vont en bénéficier et
14% un de ces projets concernent le
département des yvelines vous l'avais
dit la deuxième session est ouverte
jusqu'au 4 décembre pour le dépôt des
dossiers question très pratico pratique
vous l'avez déjà un peu évoqués qui peut
candidater qui peut déposer une
candidature et pour quels types de
projets alors toute personne morale la
seule chose pour demande mais pour une
question de responsabilité si un parti
publié c'est soit qu'ils se créent en
association soit qu il s'adosse est une
association mais pour une question de
responsabilité par rapport à l'année
pour public mais donc que deux personnes
morales collectivités associations
entreprises et on a identifié cinq
champs dans lesquels plus les dossiers
peuvent être déposés l'alimentation la
biodiversité des espaces verts quel
premier le vélo et les mobilités propre
deuxième champ troisième champ les
énergies renouvelables et les économies
d'énergie
4e chant la propreté la prévention des
déchets l'économie circulaire et enfin
la santé environnementale
donc toute personne qui souhaite déposer
un dossier
dans ce domaine là peut le faire payer
par exemple sur le premier projet on
avait ce que fut un projet d'agriculture
participative aux essarts-le-roi oudéa
nichoirs âge un oiseau est chauve souris
sur le père est donc on a comme ça
l'inde projets qui sont sortis et
d'ailleurs les yvelines a priori
candidate un peu plus fortement la juste
avant
l'émission je me suis fait sortir le
poids on est un peu plus de 200 dossiers
ont été déposés et actuellement on est
quasiment à 20 pensantes de givry noah
dont je sais pas où on sera dans une
dizaine de jours mais en tout cas les
yvelines se mobilisent encore plus
fortement que lors du premier appel à
projets avec un dépôt dossier jusqu'au 4
décembre et ensuite il y aura à cette
phase de votes sur internet à partir de
février les résultats en mars 2021
chaque francilien peut voter
concrètement peut-être franciliens
peuvent voter il suffit d'aller sur le
site budget participatif la team de
france.fr de se créer un compte pour
éviter les phénomènes de faux comptes
une touche y ait un francilien peut
voter une seule fois par projet mais
autant de fois qu'il le souhaite sur
vous pouvez voter pour trois cinq dix
projets en fonction de ce que vous
trouvez les plus méritants les plus
intéressants ils vont retrouver bien sûr
toutes les informations sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran je reprécise
les dates jusqu'au 4 décembre pour le
dépôt des candidatures vote à partir de
février les résultats connus en mars
2021 merci jean philippe dugoin clément
d'avoir est avec nous mary vice
président de la région ile de france
[Musique]
puisqu'on parle de la région en mai
dernier elle présente l acteur de son
plan de relance pour le territoire
francilien dans l' enveloppe et d'un
milliard d'euros 20 millions d'euros
étaient consacrés au monde de la culture
durement touchés on sait par la crise
sanitaire le confinement vendredi
dernier la collectivité faisait le point
sur les dispositifs d aide d'urgence en
cours et à venir
les précisions avec cette chronique de
mélanie poker le monde culturel est bien
sûr très fortement impacté 72 % de
pertes de recettes pour le spectacle
vivant le patrimoine c'est 36% 31% pour
les arts visuels
il faut savoir que 61 % des recettes du
secteur culturel sont réalisés en ile de
france alors la situation perdure avec
cette deuxième vague est la région a
choisi de maintenir les aides d'urgence
comme le maintien à 100 % des
subventions ou des aides en contrepartie
du maintien de l'emploi en termes tant
ces trois aides régionales que 8,19 à
destination du secteur culturel seront
exceptionnellement reconduite en 2021
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et ils nous préciserons
ultérieurement les modalités d'accès à
ces aides pour accompagner la
digitalisation des commerces franciliens
de moins de 10 salariés
la région propose de chèques numérique
est une aide de 1500 euros maximum
actuellement le clic une collecte
représente pour les librairies
francilienne entre 15 et 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires habituel
la région va aussi amplifier son soutien
en faveur de l'investissement culturel
en 2020 66 millions ont été investis sur
un budget de 120 millions d'euros
le long terme est aussi étudiée par la
région ile-de-france valérie pécresse
prépare un plan état région de 200
millions c'est un plan d'investissement
pluriannuel sur six ans cet
investissement
cet investissement culturel il se
traduit d'ores et déjà par un certain
nombre de projets que nous avons décidé
de soutenir
avant-hier nous avons voté une
subvention exceptionnelle de 5 millions
d'euros pour la modernisation du musée
de l'air et de l'espace du bourget que
dans le cpr enseignement supérieur il y
aura aussi un certain nombre
d'investissements
dans les écoles de la culture un groupe
de travail spécifique est en cours sur
la reprise de l'activité à l'image de
l'été culturel de 2020 la région
réfléchit déjà à celui de 2021 et face à
la fermeture des lieux culturels
certains sites cherchent tout de même à
se réinventer ce week-end à benne est la
barbacane a choisi par exemple de
continuer à faire vivre l'art avec trois
jours de concerts en live depuis son
salon directement célia gars de son goût
et mélanie poker bonsoir
bonjour importe où vous êtes sur cette
pointe la barbacane payer sa tournée ce
week-end avec la cobi 19.2 tournée
générale le rendez-vous existe depuis
cinq ans mais cette année il a dû se
renouveler en créant des apéros concerts
en temps normal orco vide dans les
villes de notre territoire à la
rencontre des gens dans un format qui
est gratuit qui est à l'heure de
l'apéritif et où on peut découvrir de
jeunes artistes émergents
dans un rapport un peu différent
puisqu'on est dans cette convivialité
autour d'une table trois soirées de
concerts en direct de la salle
installées à ben trois artistes
différents mais un point commun celui de
continuer à faire vivre la culture c'est
du spectacle vivant en théorie donc on a
l'habitude d'avoir les gens après voici
un nouveau format donc on n'a pas les
mêmes attentes et et on essaiera de
faire ce qu'on aime et le faire avec
autant de plaisir que quand les gens
sont là physiquement avec nous on a
choisi vraiment de faire une formule
intimiste pour vraiment dans
l'impression de pouvoir faire comme si
on est à la maison on rentrait chez les
gens
pour la salle c'est apéro concert était
aussi le moyen de valoriser les équipes
de l'ombre celles qui permettent un
spectacle de se tenir
et pour ceux qui seraient passés à côté
les soirées sont à retrouver sur les
pages facebook et youtube de la
barbacane à la crise sanitaire également
d'autres conséquences notamment pour
l'union inter départementale des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines qui a décidé cette
année et qu'elle ne vendrait pas de
calendrier en présentiel
il sera quand même possible d'en acheter
par chèque ou virement depuis une
plateforme en ligne aile et précision
d'astrid bergère le rendez vous annuel
n'aura pas lieu cette année les sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines ne viendront pas
te qui ont porte pour vendre leur fameux
calendrier c'est par souci d'exemplarité
qu'ils ont fait ce choix
on ne pourrait pas effectivement
imaginer que les sapeurs pompiers ne
soit pas exemplaire dans le domaine et
ne donne pas l'exemple à la population
du respect des mesures gouvernementales
liées effectivement comprennent
sanitaires il sera quand même possible
de se procurer le traditionnel
calendrier des flyers explicatives
seront distribués dans chaque boîte aux
lettres il dit noise les trois façons de
faire sont les suivantes la première en
fait à travers un tueur code qui est
imprimé en fait sur le flyer qui sera
distribuée et qui permet effectivement
un virement par correspondance la
seconde c'est la page facebook de chacun
mickeal quand elles existent
et puis la troisième c'est simplement
d'adresser un chèque par voie postale ou
amicales qui siège au centre de secours
de compétent
en fonction de l'adresse à la réception
des dons l'amicale enverra les
calendriers ces dons seront
intégralement reversés aux amicales
qu'il utilise tout au long de l'année
l'amicale de deux sapeurs pompiers en
fait est au centre de secours
l'équivalent du comité des oeuvres
sociales d'une entreprise c'est à dire
que là pour mission principalement en
fait une action sociale et solidaire
envers les sapeurs pompiers et leurs
familles elle contribue également en
fait à effectuer des dons au profit de
l'oeuvre des pupilles orphelins de
sapeurs pompiers ces dons servent aussi
à améliorer les conditions de travail au
sein des casernes
les sapeurs-pompiers appelle aussi à la
vigilance de chacun afin d'éviter les
arnaques
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal c'est notre
fil rouge cette semaine tv 60,18 vous
propose une série de portraits d'yves
ynwa qui continuent leurs engagements en
ce moment est cependant le confinement à
deux jours de la journée internationale
pour l'élimination de la violence à
l'égard des femmes rencontrent ce soir
avec louise dubray aller psychologue
clinicienne auprès de l'institut woman
safe à saint-germain-en-laye cette
association soigner accompagne les
femmes et les enfants victimes de
violence portraits signés de justin
brasier et astrid bergère psychologue
clinicienne chez human safe depuis
quatre ans louise prend en charge des
femmes victimes de violence aussi bien
physiques psychologiques sexuelles ou
encore économiques ou marseille dispose
d'une équipe complète et le travail sur
les actions à mettre en place pour aider
les patients
objectif avoir une prise en charge
globale on a des rendez vous le matin on
a les rendez vous l'après midi chaque
fin de rendez-vous bas ont fait une
prise de notes sur ce qu'il s'est passé
on contacte les professionnels
extérieurs qu'il faut contacter pour
faire du lien et pour faire le meilleur
la meilleure prise en charge possible
pour la patiente et puis en fin de
journée on a un staff donc une réunion
d'équipé est ce qui est super du coup
c'est qu'on fait du pluridisciplinaire
et que ça nous permet d'échanger en
équipe
infirmière juristes
heure lors du premier confinement une
hausse de 250% des femmes accueillies a
été constaté conséquence d'une période
qui a vu le nombre de violences
augmentent et ça a été un confinement
assez costaud parce quand j'avais
beaucoup plus de personnes à prendre en
charge et donc là ça se reproduit à peu
près aussi pendant le 2ème confinement
et c'est sur que c'est pas la même
inquiétude pour les femmes quand disons
qu'elles sont déjà coincé chez elle avec
un agresseur qui refuse qu'elle parte et
qu'il veut maintenir un contrôle sur
elle à tout prix mais quand il ya en
plus cette inquiétude de peut voir
peut-être prendre une amende quand on
sort etc
ça rajoute de l' angoisse dans ce
contexte le travail est plus intensif
pour la psychologue clinicienne de 27
ans mais louise n'en reste pas moins
passionné par son métier
j'ai la chance de faire quelque chose
qui me passionne à la fois bon c'est pas
c'était pas évident tous les jours quand
on avait ont multiplié les rendez-vous
téléphonique
avant en général j'en fais six par jour
pendant un confinement
j'en fais peut-être huit par jour aussi
à des moments parce que quand il faut il
faut multiplier les appels il faut pas
passer à côté dans le cas d'une personne
qui nous inquiète et pour lesquels il ya
peut-être une situation de danger
pour ce deuxième confinement louise
laisse le choix des consultations en
visioconférence ou en présentiel pour
assurer ses patientes et ne pas être
juste une voix au téléphone
suite de notre série de portraits à
retrouver dans notre prochaine édition
demain mardi sur tv 78 voilà le journal
touche à sa fin merci de votre fidélité
belle soirée à tous avec tv 78
[Musique]